uh good night welcome to the studio
congratulations on your first Victory
you know my first question would be show
me the critical moments of the game but
as we know your opponent blundered what
did you think just tell me what did you
feel when you saw Knight G4 at the board
on the board
um well I couldn't believe my eyes
because I thought maybe I'm
hallucinating because I was sleepy
um so I just had a look at the second
look and I was like okay just it's real
blunder so I felt bad for her actually
that is what I thought
but then well of course you have to take
a piece there and actually well I
suggested that maybe your opponent also
didn't have enough sleep so you when did
you wake up today yourself
um it was 6 a.m oh 6 a.m so you get one
hour more than everyone else I think so
yeah because this just dreadlock is just
joking Tunes but I hope that I will be
recovering in earlier like but I didn't
expect
uh you know I know that you wanted to
play this tournament so badly so your
dream came to True uh please tell us a
little bit about yourself how do you
feel in Saint Louis and why like this
tournament is so special to you well
um I really love the concept of this
tournament and uh the participants is
the priority when I played in the
tournament I did the place really good
chess players so and I do expect really
to play in my best part and I'm really
looking forward to the show really good
quality games and what did you feel
today at the start of the tournament you
still didn't know what's going to happen
like at the beginning of the game is it
anxiety anticipation you just want to
get over with us so is what are the
feelings
um I just was feeling kind of confused
because uh okay like there is some jet
lag and then there is some slippy mood
and uh I was just expecting to play it
today like a normal calm chess so to see
what I can do and she just was nervous I
think that showed itself again I think
that our audience doesn't know you that
well uh please tell us a little bit
about yourself and also about your
routine at the term how what do you do
during the chess tournaments do you
study chess from morning till evening or
well I'm 22 years old I'm from
Azerbaijan and I play for 17 years so
chess and uh what time doing during the
tournament is not seeing something
special I just checked my opponent's
games and uh get prepared
and what I'm doing else nothing just
having good work that's it
actually I had one question for you guys
which might seem strange but for example
if you would be given a choice to play
only one opening till the end of your
life which one would that be and why
um with what color well it doesn't
matter choose like let's say with white
maybe with black and Caesar for example
to choose a sicilian but uh well like I
think it would be Sicilian and with
white I guess it would be Catalan
Catalan yeah okay there's a very
different openings can you explain your
choice because like you can't really
expect what White's plans and it might
change with every game and they can make
some progresses so I do love this is
Mystery
okay and the Sicilian for because of the
aggressive attacking and stuff and I
don't know I just love the blacks plants
okay thank you so much and of course
congratulations as such a well it
started on the tournament and I hope
that we will see you more often this
studio do you know that do you know that
there is a huge bottle of champagne
which is
so maybe I think maybe Yasser wants to
ask you a question no no no no no
congratulations a nice way to start the
tournament and uh just good luck good
luck thank you absolutely